I have bizarre video of Donald Trump
rambling on CNBC which has been released
I wanted to play this yesterday just ran
out of time and among the really strange
comments that Trump makes talking about
Tesla founder Elon Musk which we'll get
to because those comments are wacky as
well Trump seems to weirdly say that the
United States invented the wheel or that
an American inventor or an American
entrepreneur invented the wheel it's
very weird video let's take a look at it
Tesla's now worth more than GM and Ford
do you have comments on Elon Musk well
you have to give him credit I spoke to
him very recently and he's also doing
the Rockets he likes rockets and he does
good at Rockets too by the way I never
saw where the engines come down with no
wings no anything and they're landing I
said I've never seen that before and I
was worried about him because he's one
of our great geniuses and we have to
protect our genius you know we have to
protect Thomas Edison and we have to
protect all of these people that came up
with originally the light bulb and the
weald and all of these things and he's
one of our very smart people and we want
to we want to cherish those people
that's very important but he's done a
very good job shocking how well you know
how it's come so fast I mean you go back
a year and they were talking about the
end of the company and now all of a
sudden they're talking about these great
things he's going to be building a very
big plant so there's a lot here let's
start with the wheel okay and then we'll
talk about Elon Musk one of the great
inventions or maybe it's a discovery in
human history was that of the wheel now
I say invention or discovery because the
physics concept of what a wheel is and
what a wheel does as a way to move mass
or to accomplish work of different kinds
it existed in nature for a long time but
we can also say that it was invented in
some specific forms by humans and
applied to our problems in any case
that's a different debate whether the
wheel was invented or discovered it
happened a very long time ago probably
the late Neolithic we have examples of
wheels actually from about 4500 BC the
potter's wheel
the earliest wheeled vehicles that
happened in conjunction with
domesticating horses that 6,500 years
ago
wants to protect great American
inventors like those who invent invented
the wheel this is a very strange thing
to say now the other side of it the
cartoonish part is we got to protect our
great American inventors who invented
the wheel the other part is he seems to
consider Elon Musk one of our great
geniuses our great geniuses he says
remember that Elon Musk is South African
not American and I wonder whether South
African immigrants are the people that
Donald Trump envisions inviting to the
United States given his view of what
immigration should be in the United
States is South Africa in the Norway
category or the S whole country category
in the mind of Donald Trump I don't know
but it seems to be completely missed on
Trump that his anti-immigration stance
is completely at odds with the countless
immigrant entrepreneurs that he often
cites as the people we want more of like
Elon Musk and Trump seemingly talking
about both Elon Musk and the wheel as
products of the United States of America
when of course neither is more
incoherence from a president that seems
to be very very unwell tell me what you
may commit a make of it I'm on Twitter
at D Pakman follow me followed the david
pakman show on twitter as well at david
pakman show we will get to your phone
calls later on in the show
I am going to address this question of
Trump's responsibility for the Ukrainian
airliner that was downed by Iran a lot
of people wrote in and said David can
you give us a sense of what
responsibility if any does Donald Trump
have for that I also got a bunch of
people writing to me after in the last
democratic debate I said Tom Steyer did
better than a lot of people Tom Steyer
did better than Budaj edge Tom Steyer
did better than Club a car and some
other people people said David who would
you vote for Biden or steyr I'm going to
address that later today
and then lastly the question of what
type of a running mate would a Bernie or
warren nominee be best informed to
consider we will talk about that later
on in the program as well quick break
calls questions a lot more coming up
today one of our sponsors is privacy
calm they're giving you $5.00 when you
sign up for their completely free
service at privacy calm slash Pakman
I've been using privacy for a little
over a year now you've heard me talk
about it before it's a lifesaver and
here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone instead of actually using your
real credit card number the privacy app
and the browser plugin let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create out of thin air
it'll even autofill the card number with
one click and the payment is taken out
of your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to 12 of these virtual credit
cards a month you can set spending
limits you can freeze them you can
delete them any time you want so when
you do this it means you're not going to
be charged when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number right after using it which for
instance I love using free trials
because I know I won't be charged when
the trial is over if I use a virtual
credit card number you're keeping your
identity private by not telling
companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or credit card
info protected against data breaches and
identity theft and it's free there's no
catch whatsoever but if you want privacy
also offers a $10 a month plan that
gives you one percent cashback and lets
you create 36 credit cards a month and a
$25 a month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create 60 card
numbers a month and much more but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like I
said you'll get $5 to spend when you
sign up at privacy calm / Pakman